Profª. Tamar Gendler: Então,
precisamos fazer 2 coisas
na aula de hoje.
A 1ª é terminar a nossa
discussão de deontologia,
que foi adiantada de propósito.
Estamos tentando dar Kant em
1 aula, basicamente.
Mas eu quero chegar ao final
desta discussão.
E a 2ª, que permitirá que
vocês usem os seus clickers
e expressem as suas opiniões,
é comentar sobre a estrutura do
artigo de Judy Thomson.
Portanto, vocês se lembram
da última aula,
em que o nosso objetivo ao
compreender a seleção de
Fundamentação da Metafísica dos
Costumes de Kant era tentar
dar sentido às 3
proposições que ele faz
no 1º capítulo do 1º volume.
E essas proposições, que eu
tenho aqui destacadas,
são as seguintes.
A 1ª afirma que, para ter valor moral,
uma ação precisa ser feita
por causa do dever.
E a distinção realizada por
Kant é a distinção
entre fazer algo em conformidade
com o dever, isto é,
algo que está em conformidade com o
que a moralidade exige de você,
e fazer algo não apenas em
conformidade com,
mas também por causa do dever.
E a imagem kantiana é que o valor
moral de uma ação é determinada
não somente por ela estar em
conformidade com o dever.
Essa é uma condição
necessária, mas não suficiente.
O que determina o valor
moral de uma ação
é que ela seja feita em
conformidade com o dever
para o bem de estar de
acordo com o dever,
isto é, ser feita por causa do dever.
A 2ª coisa que Kant diz,
a 2ª proposição que ele busca
defender na Fundamentação,
é que uma ação feita
por causa do dever
– que é o que comentávamos
na 1ª afirmação –
tem o seu valor moral
não no propósito que deve
ser atingido por ela,
não o que os gregos chamam de telos,
a sua meta, o seu objetivo,
mas sim na máxima de acordo com a
qual a ação é determinada.
Ou seja, o que determina a moralidade
da ação na imagem kantiana
é a descrição sob a qual a
ação é executada.
Agora, alguns de vocês vieram para o
horário de trabalho ontem
e nós tivemos uma discussão
animada sobre como se determinam
as coisas que contam como máximas.
E eu estimulo os que
estão interessados ??
nessa pergunta a fazerem um
curso de ética,
onde é possível trabalhar a
questão nos escritos de Kant
de forma mais detalhada.
Para efeitos desta classe,
tudo o que precisamos é nos
manter com a simples ideia
de que o que Kant está
interessado aqui são nos atos sob
uma descrição e que essa
descrição terá de satisfazer
um certo tipo de teste, como vamos
descobrir daqui a pouco.
Então, essa é a 2ª
proposição de Kant.
A 3ª alegação
é a que o dever, a noção
central da deontologia
– deon, o dever está no
núcleo da deontologia –,
é a necessidade de uma ação
por respeito à lei.
E a ideia aqui é que você não só
precisa agir com o objetivo
de estar em conformidade
com a lei em mente,
você não só precisa fazer isso
articulando as suas ações
segundo essa norma,
mas fazer isso porque você
toma a lei moral
como sendo moralmente obrigatória,
porque você reconhece que é o que a
racionalidade exige de você.
A lei moral acaba por ser a lei
que rege o comportamento
que você definiu para você
mesmo como um ser racional.
É o único aspecto do seu
comportamento na imagem kantiana
que não é determinado
pelas forças contingentes do
mundo ao seu redor.
É determinado pelo seu
reconhecimento do seu papel
como alguém capaz de obrigá-las
a uma lei definidas por elas mesmas.
Então, como eu disse, a razão
pela qual nós interessava
esses 3 princípios era chegar
à famosa formulação
do imperativo categórico de Kant.
E fechamos a última aula
conhecendo um membro da família
do imperativo categórico, em
resposta à pergunta de Kant:
"Que lei pode ser então essa,
cuja representação,
mesmo sem tomar em consideração o
efeito que dela se espera,
tem de determinar a vontade para
que esta se possa chamar
boa absolutamente e sem restrição?"
O próprio Kant aplica um
suspense à pergunta
e a responde com o 1º
membro da família
de imperativo categórico.
É "a conformidade a uma lei universal
das ações em geral" da vontade.
Só assim é possível agir de forma
autônoma e não heteronomamente.
O que significa agir de forma autônoma
em oposição a heteronomamente?
Vejamos as palavras:
autônomo, heterônomo.
Vocês podem perceber que ambas
têm nomos, ou seja, lei.
E elas distinguem a lei a que
vocês estão sujeitos
dizendo que num caso é um auto-nomos
e no outro, um hetero-nomos.
Auto-nomos.
O que poderia ser?
Vamos pensar em outras palavras,
onde temos o prefixo auto-.
Que tal automóvel?
O que é um automóvel? Um automóvel é
algo que é auto-propulsionado.
É impulsionado por sua própria força.
Atuar de forma autônoma,
na imagem de Kant,
é agir com base numa lei
imposta por você.
Você é auto-nomos, sujeito a
uma lei que vem de dentro.
Por outro lado, o que é hetero-nomos?
Bem, o que é ser heterossexual?
Ser heterossexual é se sentir
atraído sexualmente por pessoas
de um gênero diferente do seu.
Então o que é ser hetero-nomos?
É ter uma lei imposta a
você que vem de fora,
que vem de algo diferente de você.
A imagem kantiana é que a
autonomia, a autoimposição da lei,
só é possível quando a lei a que
você conforma o seu comportamento
não vem das contingências do
mundo, e sim de dentro.
Dessa forma, Kant está preocupado
com os mesmos tipos de
questionamentos que Epicteto e
Boécio.
Ambos estão profundamente preocupados
em como a liberdade humana é possível
e a imagem de Kant é que a
liberdade humana é possível
quando você governa as suas ações
com base no que você decide ser,
as normas que você pretende conformar.
Em especial,
quando você conforma as suas ações
com o imperativo categórico,
que diz, na formulação que vimos
no início desta seção,
que você deve "agir apenas
segundo uma máxima"...
aí está a sua máxima novamente...
"tal que possas ao mesmo tempo querer
que ela se torne lei universal".
Quando você age de tal modo
que não considere as
contingências da sua situação
– mas, em vez disso, pense em si
mesmo como 1 entre qualquer
milhões de seres que no seu lugar fariam
exatamente o que você faz –,
só então você se torna livre das
contingências das circunstâncias.
Portanto, a imagem é que,
em alguns aspectos,
por pisar além dos limites
das características
contingentes da sua
experiência,
por pisar além dos limites de
si mesmo, você, assim,
ganha a liberdade a partir das
contingências do mundo ao seu redor.
E Kant sugere que se você tomar
isso como uma imagem,
você vai ver que ela está em
conformidade com as regras da
racionalidade.
Então, diz ele, vamos supor que
você seja confrontado
com um caso muito particular de um
ato que você deseja executar
sob uma máxima particular.
A máxima que você definiu
para si mesmo é:
"quando eu faço uma promessa
que será complicada para mim,
eu vou quebrar essa promessa".
Ou seja, a máxima é: "está tudo bem
se eu fizer promessas falsas".
E Kant pergunta, vamos
supor que você fez,
de acordo com essa descrição,
uma promessa que você não tinha
a intenção de seguir.
Aquela máxima pode ser universalizada?
Bem, ele diz, vamos supor que ela fosse.
Vamos supor que todo mundo,
ao fazer promessas,
as façam com o pensamento de
que eles vão mantê-las
quando forem conveniente
e que não quando elas
forem inconvenientes.
Se isso ocorresse, diz Kant,
não haveria tal coisa como uma
prometedor confiável.
Por quê? Bem, porque as
promessas são marquises.
Nós não saímos a uma marquise
se há uma boa chance
de ela cair quando pisarmos nela.
E não nos arriscamos em promessas,
em compromissos feitos por
outras pessoas,
a menos que estejamos
próximos da certeza
de que essa promessa será preservada.
Portanto, diz Kant, já que a
prática de prometer seria quebrada
se todos que achassem isso
conveniente fizessem promessas
falsas,
não está em conformidade com o que
a lei moral exige de nós
fazermos uma promessa falsa.
E, Kant sugere, este quadro
pode ser estendido a todos
os tipos de tarefas.
Segundo Kant, existem 2
categorias de obrigação
para com nós mesmos e com os outros.
Nós temos deveres para com nós mesmos
e deveres para com as outras pessoas.
E, além disso, afirma Kant,
temos deveres perfeitos,
coisas que sempre temos de fazer,
e deveres imperfeitos, coisas que,
por vezes, temos de fazer.
Em todos esses casos, Kant
destaca a presença
do imperativo categórico nos
dando orientações
se uma ação sob uma
máxima é permitida.
A ação sob a máxima será permitida
se ela puder ser universalizada e
será proibida se não.
Portanto, se perguntarmos
"Está bem fazer promessas falsas?"
e dissermos para nós mesmos
"Vamos supor que todos façam
promessas falsas",
descobriremos que esse ato é proibido
pelo imperativo categórico
porque ele pode não pode
ser universalizado.
Imaginem esta questão:
"Está bem cometer suicídio ao se
sentir frustrado com o mundo?".
E Kant diz: vamos supor que
todos façam isso.
A prática, o argumento
complicado poderia ser quebrado,
porque não sobraria
ninguém para se suicidar.
Então aqui vai o argumento.
Vamos supor que nos perguntem
se temos o dever de cultivar
os nossos talentos?
Kant afirma: vamos supor que
ninguém cultive os seus talentos.
O mundo no qual vivemos seria um mundo
em que ninguém gostaria de viver.
E, consequentemente, temos a
obrigação moral de fazê-lo.
Por fim, ele pergunta:
nós temos a obrigação de dar
dinheiro aos necessitados?
E continua:
o que aconteceria se fosse
uma lei universal
que ninguém desse dinheiro
aos necessitados?
E mais uma vez descobrimos uma
ruptura de um mundo ordenado
em que queremos sobreviver.
Bom, há espaço para o
questionamento...
Na verdade, há espaço para
questionar todas essas 4 derivações,
embora seja geralmente aceito
que a da promessa falsa é a
mais eficaz delas.
Mas em vez do que Kant diz sobre elas,
vamos analisar se estas
derivações funcionam.
Kant afirma:
"Estes são apenas alguns dos
muitos deveres reais
cuja derivação do princípio
único ressalta bem clara".
"Bem clara" é um pouco exagerado,
mas podemos ver como seria
essa derivação.
O que isso nos diz sobre a moralidade?
Para Kant, nos diz que
quando pegamos um ato
e tentamos determinar se ele é moral,
é preciso checar e ver
se estamos criando uma
exceção para nós mesmos.
Quando agimos, temos de ser
capazes de querer
que uma máxima de nossas ações
se torne uma lei universal.
Quando transgredimos, diz Kant,
não querer que a nossa máxima se
torne uma lei universal,
mas sim que o oposto dessa máxima
continue sendo uma lei universal.
Então, vamos supor que você
goste de se sentar
nos últimos 2 assentos de uma fila,
mesmo sem chegar atrasado.
Você quer que isso se torne
uma lei universal
ou é algo que só funciona para você
se os outros estão dispostos a se
sentar mais para dentro,
de modo que haja espaço nas laterais?
Kant diria que a lei moral exige de
você se mover para dentro,
porque sentar nesses 2
últimos assentos,
apesar de não ter chegado tarde,
depende de outras pessoas
fazerem algo diferente.
Roubar depende de outras pessoas
respeitarem as leis de forma adequada.
Não pagar a passagem de metrô
depende de outras pessoas
pagarem a passagem,
de modo que haja dinheiro
suficiente para manter o metrô.
Quando você faz uma exceção
para si mesmo, diz Kant,
você viola a lei moral.
E vamos voltar a isso
na abertura da nossa discussão
sobre filosofia política,
quando falamos sobre os
dilemas do prisioneiro.
Agora, eu mencionei rapidamente que
vocês conheceram um membro
da família do imperativo categórico,
algo que às vezes é chamado
de a fórmula da lei universal
... que alguém só deve agir em
conformidade com aquela máxima
pela qual você quer, ao mesmo tempo,
que se torne uma lei universal.
Kant situa os imperativos
categóricos de 4 maneiras
diferentes
por uma série de motivos.
Um deles, diz Kant, é que
em certos casos
é mais fácil ver como aplicar o
imperativo categórico
se o enquadrarmos numa forma
ligeiramente diferente.
Eu quero apresentá-los às outras 3,
em grande parte porque a 2ª vai
desempenhar um papel central
na metade final da aula de hoje.
Portanto, Kant alega que
dizer para agir de tal maneira
que a sua máxima se torne
uma lei universal
é o equivalente a dizer:
"de tal maneira que use a humanidade,
tanto na tua pessoa como na
pessoa de qualquer outro,
sempre e simultaneamente como fim e
nunca simplesmente como meio".
Não se use como um meio para um fim
e não use os outros nas suas
interações com eles simplesmente
como meio.
Trate a humanidade e todos os
outros como fins em si mesmos.
O equivalente a isso, diz Kant, é
a fórmula da autonomia,
que nós já comentamos.
Aja pela sua máxima, de modo que
você possa ser um legislador
das leis universais.
Aja de tal maneira que você
é o autolegislador
em relação às regras
endossadas pela razão.
E, finalmente, uma noção
bastante complicada,
às vezes chamada de o reino dos fins...
agir de acordo com as máximas de
um membro determinando
leis universais para um
possível reino dos fins.
Uma sociedade harmoniosa em
que todo mundo existe
conforme as leis definidas por você.
Como eu disse, temos apenas
cerca de 1 hora para Kant,
por isso não vamos abordar o 3º e 4º.
Mas eu quero chamar a atenção de vocês
para a fórmula da humanidade,
porque ela vai desempenhar
um papel central
no diagnóstico de Judy Thomson,
do que pode estar ocorrendo
em nossas intuições
sobre os casos do Trolley.
Então deixa eu fechar a discussão de
Kant tentando reconectá-la
à miniunidade da qual ela faz parte.
Vocês devem se lembrar que nós
começamos esta seção do curso
na última quinta-feira
pensando no consequencialismo
como uma teoria moral.
E a pergunta que eu quero fazer é:
o que as 2 teorias morais
concretas têm em comum
na nossa abordagem de
início desta unidade?
Até agora, vimos algumas
das diferenças
entre o consequencialismo
e a deontologia.
Mas eu acho que é importante,
passando para algumas de suas
aplicações práticas,
refletir sobre o que elas têm em comum.
E o que elas têm em comum é
que tanto a teleologia,
o consequencialismo – utilitarismo, na
forma particular que encontramos –
e a deontologia proíbem a
excepcionalidade da 1ª pessoa.
Kant afirma: o meu desejo
pode servir de base
para as ações intencionais só se
eu puder, simultaneamente,
de forma coerente, querer que os outros,
em circunstâncias semelhantes,
ajam da mesma forma que eu
estou escolhendo agir.
Eu só estou autorizado a
fazer as coisas assumindo
que as outras pessoas também
estão autorizadas a fazê-las.
E Bentham, citado em Mill... Bentham, o
bisavô do utilitarismo, diz:
"todo mundo conta por um,
ninguém por mais de um".
Mill, no seu princípio da
maior felicidade,
fala do bem-estar de todos,
não do bem-estar do ponto
de vista subjetivo.
Portanto, o desafio da moralidade é
ver o mundo não da postura
das suas próprias necessidades
como o conjunto mais central
das necessidades do mundo,
mas sim da perspectiva
das suas próprias necessidades como
o conjunto de necessidades
entre os 6 bilhões de seres
igualmente sencientes.
O problema da moralidade
é que a tendência para a
excepcionalidade da 1ª pessoa,
a de tomar as suas próprias
necessidades como mais importantes
que as necessidades de
qualquer outra pessoa,
talvez seja o viés psicológico
mais difundido e onipresente.
E quando chegarmos à unidade
sobre filosofia política,
após a pausa de março,
falaremos sobre as formas que
as estruturas sociais
são postas em prática para ajudar a
lidar com esse tipo de tensão.
Mesmo nos trechos de Mill da
quinta-feira passada,
ele fala sobre que tipo de atitudes é
importante cultivar nos indivíduos
para que eles comecem a ver o mundo
sob uma perspectiva moral.
Nos enxertos que lemos no Livro X
do Ética a Nicômaco,
Aristóteles pergunta:
de que forma a sociedade
deve ser estruturada
para tornar mais fácil que as
pessoas ajam moralmente?
E, de certa forma, a questão com a
qual vamos encerrar o curso
– como funciona a persuasão
racional versus a não-racional,
quais são os papéis dos literários
em oposição às representações
argumentativos da boa vida –
é uma versão
operacionalizada deste
dilema.
Dada uma tendência humana
inevitável a considerar
as nossas necessidades como mais
importantes que a dos outros,
como é possível estruturar a sociedade
de tal forma que as necessidades
de todos sejam atendidas?
É isso que eu quero dizer sobre Kant.
E para restante da aula,
peguem os seus clickers e
aproveitem o passeio.
Portanto, como vocês
sabem, o texto de hoje
é um grande e complexo artigo da
filósofa Judith Jarvis Thomson,
escrito em meados dos anos 1980, em
resposta a um artigo anterior
de outra filósofa, da metade do
século passado, Philippa Foot.
E Philippa Foot e Judy Thomson
estão interessadas
na exploração sistemática de uma
série de casos que parece evocar,
na maioria dos indivíduos,
intuições muito fortes sobre qual
é a coisa certa a fazer,
mas que parece apresentar intuições
para a explicação
difícil de sistematizar.
Então, como vocês sabem bem,
este é o 1º caso,
que chamaremos de o
maquinista do trem...
aqui está ele.
Há um trem desgovernado pelos trilhos,
de tal forma que matará 5 pessoas.
Mas acontece que existe outra via
para a qual o trem pode ser desviado,
onde está somente 1 pessoa.
E a pergunta agora é esta.O
maquinista está conduzindo o trem.
O trem vai em direção a 5 pessoas,
de tal modo que matará as 5.
O maquinista está moralmente
obrigatório, moralmente proibido
ou, talvez, nem proibido nem
exigido, mas apenas permitido,
a desviar o trem, onde está
somente 1 pessoa?
Agora observem que, embora esteja
enquadrado como um problema
idealizado, o desvio de ameaças é algo
que os tomadores de decisão
enfrentam o tempo todo.
Vamos supor que um avião com
problemas esteja em queda
e ele deve pousar numa cidade grande,
e existe a possibilidade de desviá-lo
para cair numa área menos povoada.
Vamos supor que exista uma doença
que esteja tirando a vida
de muitas pessoas,
mas se as colocarmos em quarentena,
causando a morte desse número,
o resto da população será salva.
Caso após caso, estamos
diante de dilemas
com mais ou menos a
estrutura do Trolley.
Portanto, embora estes casos
sejam idealizados,
no sentido de que estamos
concedendo a nós mesmos
a certeza dos resultados,
este não é, penso eu, um
exercício inútil,
mesmo que a nossa preocupação seja
com a moralidade do mundo real,
refletir sobre a coisa certa a fazer.
Então vamos começar com o caso
do maquinista do trem.
O trem vai pelos trilhos
de tal forma que o maquinista matará
5 pessoas se não o desvia.
Ele enfrenta a escolha de virar
o trem para o trilho
onde está 1 pessoa.
Questão: É moralmente obrigatório
desviar um trem de 5 pessoas para 1?
É moralmente permitido, mas não
moralmente obrigatório,
desviar o trem de 5 pessoas para 1?
Ou é moralmente proibido
OK. E vamos ver os números que saem.
Eu vou anotá-los, porque vamos
precisar deles mais tarde.
Assim, 7% de vocês, um
número muito pequeno,
acham que é moralmente proibido
para ele desviar o trem.
A grande maioria, perto dos 2/3, acha
que é moralmente permitido,
mas não moralmente
obrigatório, ele desviar o
trem.
E cerca de 30% de vocês, 1/3,
acham que ele está moralmente
obrigado a fazer tal manobra.
Caso número dois: Transplante.
Você trabalha num hospital.
5 pessoas dão entrada no hospital,
todas destinadas a morrer,
porque 1 precisa de um
pulmão, 1 de um coração,
1 de um rim, 1 de um fígado
e 1 de um cérebro.
Então, elas estão prestes a
morrer e você é o médico.
E, na sala de emergência,
entra um jovem perfeitamente
saudável que tem um coração,
um pulmão, um fígado, um rim
e um cérebro ativos.
Se você fatiar o homem
e dar as partes dele aos 5
indivíduos em agonia,
você pode salvar os 5 a custo de 1.
Questão: Para o médico, é A)
moralmente obrigatório
fatiar o homem saudável
para salvar os 5;
B) moralmente permitido,
mas não moralmente obrigatório
fatiar o homem saudável;
ou C) moralmente proibido
fatiar o homem saudável?
Então vamos ver os números
que saem. Portanto...
85% de vocês acham que é
moralmente proibido
cortar 1 pessoa para salvar 5.
9% de vocês acham que é
moralmente permitido,
mas não moralmente obrigatório.
E 6% – fiquem longe do
curso de Medicina! –
acha que é moralmente
obrigatório fatiar o homem.
Então o que está acontecendo aqui?
Philippa Foot, a pessoa que inicialmente
apresentou esta justaposição,
tem uma hipótese.
E a hipótese dela é esta.
Que no caso do maquinista,
a escolha que ele enfrenta é
entre matar 1 e matar 5.
Ao passo que, no caso do transplante,
a escolha enfrentada pelo médico é
entre matar 1 e deixar 5 morrerem.
Se colocamos isso num gráfico, que eu
chamarei de "medidor-do-mau",
que nos diz o quão ruim as coisas são,
descobrimos que deixar 5
pessoas morrerem é ruim,
mas matar é pior, e matar
5 é ainda pior.
E parece que isso nos dá a resposta
que matar 5 é pior que matar 1,
portanto no caso do maquinista,
está bem ele desviar o trem,
mas como matar 1 é pior que
deixar 5 morrerem,
no caso do médico, não está
bem fatiar 1 homem.
Porque no caso do médico, você tem
de matar 1 para salvar 5,
enquanto que no caso do trem,
o maquinista tem de matar 1 a
fim de não matar 5.
E isso parece estar muito bem de acordo
com as intuições de vocês.
93% acham que é permitido, no
caso do trem, desviá-lo,
enquanto que apenas 14%
acham que é permitido,
no caso do médico, matar o homem.
Portanto, parece que
medidor-do-mau é muito bom em
captar
a intuição dos presentes nesta sala.
E, de fato, os estudos
empíricos realizados
em milhares de pessoas em todo o mundo
sugerem que as intuições de vocês
estão praticamente alinhadas
com as intuições da maioria.
Mas há um problema.
Caso número 3: testemunha do trem.
Aqui está Jim.
Coitado do Jim.
Muito azar.
1º, ele aparece numa
cidade latino-americana
e tem de atirar em alguns índios.
Agora, aqui está ele, próximo
a um trem desgovernado
que está a ponto de matar 5 pessoas.
Mas aqui, no meio da via, há uma
alavanca que possibilita a Jim
desviar o trem para matar 1.
Questão: Para Jim, a testemunha,
é moralmente obrigatório
desviar o trem de modo que,
em vez de o trem se chocar com
5 pessoas, atinja 1?
É moralmente permitido,
mas não moralmente obrigatório
para ele desviar o trem?
Essa é a resposta 2.
Ou é moralmente proibido para
ele desviar o trem?
Vamos ver como saem estes números.
OK. E aqui estão os seus números.
15, 70, 15.
Eles são muito parecidos
com a distribuição de respostas
dada no caso do maquinista.
No caso do maquinista,
63% de vocês acharam que era
moralmente permitido,
ao passo que agora 70% acham que
é moralmente permitido.
No caso do maquinista,
30% acharam que era
moralmente obrigatório.
Desta vez, um pouco menos acha que é
moralmente obrigatório:15%.
E, no caso do maquinista, 7% de
vocês acharam que era proibido.
Aqui, 15% acham que é
moralmente proibido.
Portanto, há uma pequena
mudança, mas não muita.
Aqui está o problema.
Lembrem-se que na análise
do caso de Foot,
sabíamos que deixar 5 pessoas
morrerem era um pouco ruim,
que matar 1 era pior e que
matar 5 era ainda pior.
O maquinista enfrentou a escolha
de matar 1 contra matar 5.
No transplante, você enfrenta
a escolha de matar 1
contra deixar 5 morrerem.
Mas o que sucede no caso da testemunha?
Bem, no caso da testemunha,
Jim, o azarado Jim,
enfrenta uma escolha entre matar 1
– desviando o trem de tal forma
que Jim mata este cara –
ou deixar 5 morrerem.
Deixar o trem atingir 5 pessoas, que
seriam atingidas inevitavelmente.
Mas em contraste com o caso do médico,
onde 85% de vocês acharam que
era proibido matar 1
para salvar 5 pessoas que, de
outra forma, morreriam;
neste caso, 85% de vocês acham que
é, no mínimo, permitido
matar 1 para evitar a morte de 5.
Vou fazer isso novamente.
85% de vocês... vejam o medidor... acham
que ele vai para o outro lado.
O que está acontecendo agora?
Pensávamos que tínhamos uma
solução para o problema.
A solução para o problema que
diferenciava o transplante do maquinista
foi a distinção entre
matar e deixar morrer.
E, de repente, muitos de vocês
parecem estar dizendo,
no caso da testemunha, que deixar 5
morrerem é pior que matar 1.
Vocês devem achar ou
não deveriam achar
que é moralmente permitido
para ele desviar o trem.
Mas a coisa fica ainda pior.
Vamos supor no caso do
hospital da seguinte forma.
5 indivíduos saudáveis
??apresentam-se no hospital e um
médico
– seja porque ele está cansado ou
porque ele quer obter os benefícios
do seguro em que é um beneficiário
caso haja muitos pacientes
doentes no seu hospital –
envenena os 5,
de tal forma que 1 deles
precisa de um fígado,
1 precisa de um rim, 1 de
pulmões, 1 de um coração
e 1 precisa de um cérebro.
E assim, como resultado do
que esse homem fez,
essas 5 pessoas vão morrer.
E algumas horas mais tarde, ele pensa:
"Oh! Eu esqueci o
imperativo categórico!
Droga! O que eu vou fazer?"
E entra um indivíduo
saudável e ele pensa:
"Ah, ótimo! Eu tenho uma solução,
aqui, eu posso cortá-lo.
Coração, pulmão, rins,
fígado, cérebro...
posso salvar os 5. OK".
Questão: Para o médico que envenenou
os 5 indivíduos do hospital,
que enfrenta agora a opção de
salvar as vidas deles
matando 1, é
A) moralmente obrigatório
cortar o homem saudável;
B) moralmente permitido,
mas não é moralmente obrigatório
fatiar o homem saudável;
ou C) moralmente proibido
cortar o homem saudável?
E vamos ver os números que saem.
Tudo bem. So.
82%, 11%, 7%.
Os seus números aqui são
quase idênticos
ao que eram no caso original do médico.
Daquela vez, foram 6, 9 e 85;
aqui são 7, 11 e 82.
Quase não há diferença.
Mas vamos voltar ao nosso
medidor-do-mau.
Vamos deixar de lado a questão
de matar e deixar morrer
e nos concentrar em matar
1 contra matar 5.
Nós sabemos pelo maquinista do trem
que matar 1 é muito ruim.
Mas de acordo com a maioria de vocês,
de acordo com 93%, matar 5
é pior que matar 1.
OK. Médico do veneno.
Aqui está a escolha
enfrentada pelo médico.
Ele pode matar 5... certo? Ele os
envenenou e agora eles vão morrer.
Ou ele pode matar 1, um cara
saudável, que acaba de aparecer.
E os outros 5 não vão morrer.
82% de vocês me disseram que era
melhor ele matar 5 que matar 1.
Deixa eu mostrar isso de
novo, no medidor.
85% de vocês acharam que era
melhor ele matar 5 que matar 1.
Então, temos esses 2
excelentes princípios
que parecem explicar o que
ocorria no caso do trem.
Por um lado, que matar 1 era pior
que deixar 5 morrerem e,
então, de repente, a
testemunha nos faz pensar:
Oh, não, nós não temos
essa intuição.
Temos a intuição de que matar 1 deles
era melhor que matar 5...
e o caso do veneno nos faz
repensar isso outra vez.
Agora, há uma questão óbvia
que pode estar fazendo a
diferença moral aqui.
Há uma diferença temporal
entre quando acontece a morte
de 1 e a morte de 5.
E talvez, diz Thomson,
isso é o que explica a nossa
intuição, no caso do médico.
Talvez seja porque a morte de 5 se
tornou um deixar morrer,
como resultado do tempo, que é enganoso
descrever isso como um caso de
matar 1 contra matar 5.
Mas o temporal não atua
no caso do transplante
versus o da testemunha.
Parece muito claro que em ambos casos
se enfrenta a escolha entre matar
1 e deixar 5 morrerem.
E ao passo que isso parecia
bastante claro para a maioria
de vocês no transplante,
que matar 1 era pior que
deixar 5 morrerem,
na testemunha,
parece bastante claro o contrário.
Portanto, o problema do trem
é o problema levantado por
estas setas de dança.
Como é que sistematizamos as
nossas intuições sobre matar
e deixar morrer, já que elas
parecem desconexas?
Thomson sugere que ainda que o
caso do transplante
nos dê uma escolha entre matar
1 e deixar 5 morrerem,
como o da testemunha,
existe uma diferença relevante
de potencial entre eles.
E isso porque, no caso do transplante,
você está usando 1
pessoa como um meio.
Você está usando-a como uma forma
de alcançar o resultado
de salvar os outros 5.
Ao passo que, na testemunha,
quando você desvia o trem para a
via onde um indivíduo está,
você não está usando esse
indivíduo como um meio e...
oh meu Deus, eu disse que
voltaríamos a Kant, e aqui estamos!
O que diz a fórmula da
humanidade de Kant?
A fórmula da humanidade de
Kant diz para agir
"de tal maneira que use a humanidade,
tanto na tua pessoa como na
pessoa de qualquer outro,
sempre e simultaneamente como fim
e nunca simplesmente como meio".
Talvez essa seja a nossa solução.
Talvez o problema na testemunha
seja que como você não está
tratando como um meio,
não há problema em matar 1.
Enquanto que, no transplante,
você está tratando como um meio,
não está bem matar 1 e,
consequentemente,
você é moralmente obrigado a
deixar os 5 morrerem.
Bem, diz Thomson, isso
não é bem assim.
Vamos supor que você seja o Jim,
de pé ao lado do trem.
O trem está no seu caminho habitual
para matar 5.
Mas em vez da via em linha reta,
há uma via em circuito, e 1
pessoa está no meio da via
de tal forma que se você
desviar o trem,
ele vai bater nela,
salvando as outras 5.
Questão. No caso em que Thomson
chama de "circuito", é
A) moralmente obrigatório
desviar o trem.
B) Moralmente permitido, mas não
moralmente obrigatório;
ou C) moralmente proibido?
Lembrem-se que trem está indo na via
em direção às 5 pessoas.
Você é o Jim.
O trem vai atingir os 5
ou você pode desviar o trem
para a via com 1,
e porque há 1 pessoa lá, você
fará com que o trem pare.
OK? Então vamos ver os
números que saem desta vez.
OK. 68, 18, 14.
Não muita diferentes.
Vocês responderam quase da mesma forma
que responderam a todos os outros
casos envolvendo o trem.
Em geral, a distribuição
foi de 15, 70, 15.
Essa foi a da testemunha.
Desta vez: 14, 68, 18.
Mas observem que, neste caso,
vocês estavam usando o cara
na via como um meio!
Vocês estão usando ele como
um meio para o seu fim.
Vocês estão tentando parar o
trem usando o corpo dele.
Kant não nos ajudou em
nada! Reabastecendo.
Vamos fazer um novo
balanço, diz Thomson.
Talvez um pouco do trabalho
esteja sendo feito
por alguma noção de direitos.
Talvez o que esteja acontecendo
no caso do transplante,
aquele em que vocês não deixam que o
médico fatie o homem saudável,
é que você estaria violando
os direitos do homem.
E talvez seja verdade que
"os direitos triunfem
sobre a utilidade".
Isto é, que quando alguém tem
direito à integridade física,
isso tem prioridade sobre as
necessidades de muitos.
As utilidades dos 5 que serão salvos.
E vamos terminar esta aula com
um último exemplo,
destinado a testar essa hipótese.
E vamos começar a próxima aula falando
sobre algumas das razões que as
pessoas tendem a dar esta resposta.
Vamos supor agora que, em vez do
circuito, exista uma ponte.
E que naquela ponte esteja um
senhor bastante gordo.
E agora vocês enfrentam o
seguinte dilema.
O trem segue pelos trilhos.
Está prestes a matar 5 pessoas.
E assim é como Jim, a
testemunha, pode pará-lo.
Ele pode empurrar o homem gordo
da ponte e fazer com
que o trem pare devido ao peso do homem.
Questão. Para a
testemunha no homem gordo,
é moralmente obrigatório empurrá-lo,
moralmente permitido, mas não
moralmente obrigatório,
ou moralmente proibido empurrá-lo?
Vamos dar as respostas e eu vou
deixar vocês com esses números
e uma observação sobre eles
em nosso encerramento.
Então, vamos ver se temos alguma
mudança no caso do homem gordo.
Meu Deus! Isso parece
completamente diferente.
O que está acontecendo?
Lembrem-se que a nossa
distribuição clássica
é a que temos uns 70% aqui, e não
mais de 10% em proibido.
De repente, 78% de vocês
pensam que é proibido.
O que está acontecendo?
Suspense!
Falaremos sobre isso na terça.